beaucoup d'experts expliquent que le
petit écran est périmé mais la
sociologie rappelle qu'en milieu
populaire la télévision fonctionne quasi
en permanence on peut y voir une preuve
concrète de l'aliénation des classes
dominées pendues devant la télé
expression d'ailleurs lourdes de
sous-entendu pendu comme si le sang
n'arrive plus au cerveau ou comme si le
fait d'être avachi sur le canapé était
le signe d'une apathie la place de la
télévision est d'autant plus importante
qu'aujourd'hui les écrans sont larges de
plus d'un mètre et occupent une place
centrale dans la pièce à vivre on ne
recouvre plus le poste avec un chiffon
brodé on ne le cache pas dans un meuble
cette pratique s'observerait plutôt dans
les classes moyennes d'aujourd'hui
l'intérieur s'organise autour de l'objet
onéreux qui sert le plus souvent et
auprès duquel les familles mais aussi
les amis se rassemblent la télé est même
allumée exprès lorsqu'on a du monde à la
maison cet extrait est issu du livre de
Benoît Coquard ceux qui restent faire sa
vie dans les campagnes en déclin aux
éditions La Découverte